she's just spreading legs legs spread
out just looking at you licking her lips
all sorts of she couldn't she can stop
the story
let's move on
no
no
no
[Music]
guys
it's monday sunday it's fun day you know
the vibes we've got the vibes
matt's making off as well
this is the last time you're gonna see
us in the studio please oh yeah this is
the last time you're going to see your
boys in this studio no not this time not
next week not this week next week
yeah this is the last time oh the last
period of time yes yes yes yes yes no
this is yeah this is the last video
they'll see this in the studio oh yeah
true [ __ ] hell
yeah yeah yeah this is the last video
i'll just make sure this is the last
video you'll see us in the studio
so
enjoy it i mean
truth be told
we're bringing all of our [ __ ] to the
new studio you probably won't even be
able to tell it's probably gonna look
similar it's gonna look pretty much the
same
i'm pretty sure it's a white wall it is
a white wall in there we're gonna be
bringing all the same [ __ ] so you guys
won't tell won't be able to tell but we
wouldn't we'll know and there'll just be
different energy in the room yeah
completely different different energy in
the room so um yeah man hopefully this
last one bangs in here we've had uh a
whale of a time in here it's been a year
man yeah it's been a year guys it's
flown by in it flown by it
i was looking back at some episodes when
we first first moved in
and we didn't have like the neon or the
r yeah all the lamps they're
bare minimum it looks dry
but we were gas to be here of course bro
of course bro it was it was a start of a
new era it was and i was at the end of
the era i'm going to start a new one
soon yeah man i'm excited and it's just
made up
it's made our work so much easier to to
do 100 every time we come in here sit
down
and we're just like bang let's go have a
sip sip have a monster and we're just
like let's go let's get into it
obviously before it was sick but before
it was just like it was a lot more work
i have so much more so much more hassle
to set everything up yeah yeah setting
everything up every time and then just
[ __ ]
you get in there and you're just like
ugh
like because we're already in the same
sofa that we've been in for the last
three hours yeah yeah yeah and now it's
time to turn on the podcast mode and
it's like big man i can't it's hard to
do that yeah i can't yeah i don't know
what so this is studio has been great
yeah i'm looking forward to the
aerospace thank you as jimmy said thank
you for
providing this for us you know getting
us here you know we're looking forward
to your space yeah man and um
i was saying the other day
when we um when we first got that we
couldn't even afford this studio when we
got it
we literally couldn't afford it we
couldn't um and now the next stage is
even more expensive than this one yeah
man that is
the up and up yes it's gang so there you
go thank you um thank you guys that's
all on you yeah mum um
so guys before we get into the nitty
gritty um
you already know what you need to do if
you haven't done it already
move on over to patreon.com
forward slash shits and gigs
it's three pound a month it's 10 p a day
run the p and you get 50 say everything
that you've been experiencing on these
mondays
double it double it and you get that on
thursdays now so when you're doing that
drive to work
and on a tuesday morning and you'll
catch us this is what i used to do so i
listen to podcasts that come out on
mondays and when i used to do when your
boy had a job
when your boy had a job when your boy
was on that rat race thing i would get
up on a
on a monday morning a dry cold monday
morning dry cold monday morning actually
no not monday morning on a tuesday
morning because on the monday morning it
wouldn't be out yet they used to come
out on monday they wouldn't be able to
watch them on the channel
um
i'll get in there and i will be gassed
i'll be gas thinking at least i've got
this to listen to at the very least i've
got this to listen to so he used to make
the commute cause my commute was like an
hour and a half
um every morning and every evening back
it was hell that doesn't sound okay
feminism it wasn't that's not right
it wasn't bro that's not right hour and
a half on a good day that's not okay on
a good day i've got a bad day on a bad
busy day on half term i used to be
gassed
i'll breeze to work
on them busy school days yeah it could
take two hours plus nah man it was dead
bro to work to work they need to pay for
that right we might need to
work need to supplement these expenses
bro trust me it was dead so
um
obviously i would listen to my favorite
podcasts
tuesday morning
so they would release the ones i used to
listen to would release monday and
wednesday so i would listen to them
tuesday and thursday and i knew tuesday
and thursday mornings i'm gassed
um gas tuesday and thursday mornings it
doesn't matter where i'm at yeah so yeah
guys you can have that too on those
tuesdays and friday mornings let your
boys take care of you you're in it you
look good
listen to that great way to start the
week great way to end the week look
after the emails about that
beginning and end of the week you're
handled
your hand you're patterned turn on the
seat heated seats and just slide into
that window's coming
wind
um
so head on over there to patreon
actually that reminds me actually we've
got a big announcement for patreon
big announcement for patreon you didn't
even know what i'm going to say to you i
don't think so that's one way we spoke
about it 9 000 times but it's fine
gotta announce it now okay um so guys on
patreon
the current model looks like this
three pounds i know we're going to say
gang
this is what the current model looks
like and i'm gonna tell you what we're
gonna do for you now yeah so if you're a
patron listen up especially yeah if
you're about to be a patron listen up
especially more right so this is what
the current model looks like on patreon
you've got three or four four tears
first here
is three pound a month
tempe a day that's where you get your
bonus episodes every thursday you log in
you check in you pay your three pound
you get every thursday taken care of
bang that's your episode
you up that to ten pound a month that's
tier two that is there too you get early
access to these episodes
and you get 30 off all of our merch
you up that again to tier three 20 pound
a month
you get
exclusive access to us
every single month
for a live zoom chat with us every month
now
that's been gang the ones that we've
done have been very good have been very
[ __ ] great very pleasure everything
else by the way obviously sorry yeah
everything else as well so um
what we're gonna do guys don't forget
the hundred pound one hundred pound a
month with a hundred pound one you get
bear [ __ ] you'll have to find that one
to yourself that's tier four yeah that's
the juicy that's the juicy
that's the deep pocket cat juice yeah
yeah yeah yeah she knows about that yeah
he had a few different dim their toes in
there that's that deep pocket yeah but
guys what we're gonna do for you guys
now
is we're going to give you guys more
access to us because obviously you guys
have heard about us out so much you've
changed our lives you've done so much
for us so this is one thing that we want
to do for you
we're going to
scribble out tier three that's gone
we're getting rid of tier three it's
gone now
so guys
we've got tier one and tier two for tier
one exactly the same three pound a month
tempe a day run the p every thursday
you're taken care of
tier 2 is juicy now 10 pound a month now
it's healthy it's juicy now no one's
healthy now you're getting that bang for
your buck so as well as a bonus episode
as well as a thank you message you now
get early access to the episode okay you
get 30 off the merch okay everything
else in the previous tier you get the
monthly
chat with your boys your favorite duo
your co-hosts your [ __ ] second and
biggest podcast in the world second
biggest podcast
we'll send out the links to you every
month and we'll all tune in we'll build
a community we're going to build a cult
at the end of the day let's just be
let's be honest the smg cult is yeah the
sng call obviously is going to happen
eventually it's going to take over might
as well just speak about it openly now
yeah we're starting a cult and we want
you guys to be part of that so you get
all of that for ten pounds ten pounds
that's it sign up ten pound a month and
you get all of that and we're gonna chat
to you guys every month you guys get to
meet each other maybe you're gonna
chirps a thing in the zoom i don't know
we don't know
we don't know we don't know what's going
to happen in those zooms they could get
crazy they could get you last time we're
in on the zoom we had one darn sitting
in flipping australia australia it was
five o'clock in the morning we had us it
was like eight o'clock in the evening we
had another in a movie in chicago it was
like two o'clock in the afternoon and
she was cracking open some wine bro it
was all over the gap it was all over the
gaffe so yeah crazy
so guys jump on in if you're three pound
and you want to jump to to get all the
juicy juice you can do that now if
you're nothing and you want to jump
straight in in that juicy juice
that's cool it's only 10 it's only 10
pound a month if you want to secure
juicy juice
um
again this is something we want to do
for you we want to give you guys as much
bank feedback as possible so tier three
is gone you got tier one and you got
tier two the choice is up to you um
and without further ado we're over tofu
is it do what it do
[Music]
man should a rhyme these days say no
more
all right um i've got uh interesting
sorry to cut you off you know i've just
realized these men are going to see me
live drinking butter
of course they are like a white of
course they are but that's not your
fault it's not my fault that's not your
fault the economy's fault yeah the
economy is moving mad these days like
petrol is a scam water's a scam cutlery
and crockery is a scam import export is
a scam so we just need to patent science
yeah so don't blame james yeah yeah
that's not blatantly he just needs his
he needs i need to hydrate he needs to
hide i actually need hydration i don't
have a choice it's compulsory yeah i
didn't have a choice all right so allow
me now we've made that clear
i needed to address that because if i
didn't a man lit me up in the comments i
would have been vexed it was slated you
would have covered swear boxton yes yeah
boxing on camera this guy's got no shame
yeah anyway
anyway um so i found this actually
really cool fun fact so there's a street
artist called kevin lee and he's made a
portrait called the invisibility of
poverty
um there's a child that's depicted
sitting on the stairs being stepped on
and stepped over to illustrate how
invisible the poor living the poor are
living amongst us and i've actually got
a picture of the actual
art that he's drawn
oh [ __ ]
so for the audio listeners
obviously for the visual listeners it's
on your screen right here um for the
audio listeners it what it looks like is
you've just got a stairs like to like to
like a subway and you've got a little
kid literally painted on the stairs
and it actually looks like there's a kid
sitting on there
and it looks real it just shows how
people in the day-to-day life walk past
poor people they get walked all over
they get walked all over and they just
get ignored completely
it's a serious art in it bro is that a
ridiculous art it's some serious art the
guy's name is kevin lee and i saw it i
was like
wow and what a title is called the
invisibility of poverty that's a gang
title i'm i'm part of the problem you
definitely are
you definitely are you don't see you
don't see poverty that's a lie
i'm joking i'm joking i'm joking i'm
joking i'm outside of your sheets
i just get on with your life i do get on
with my life but there are times where i
think the last time i gave um
a homeless person some money was it was
a while ago to fail probably like a year
ago a year and a half
carry cash like that that's another
thing i ne i rarely ever carry cash i
don't even carry my wallet with me sam i
always only ever carry my phone because
apple pay did i tell you when i got this
phone i couldn't pay for food one day
the new phone did i tell you
vex me i'm glad actually
i'm glad because the amount of times
you've told me i ain't got my wallet on
me
and i'm like wife and why why why have
you not got your wallet on you and
you're like apple pay in it apple pay oh
you needed to get cash out and you're
like oh apple pay
apple pay nine i could do it we went to
get food that time and i had to run
around looking for cash because their
card machine wasn't working i can't even
remember then and we needed to split it
i covered you it was me you and jay we
went to that spot okay okay okay okay
okay okay okay okay okay okay
i don't bring my wallet anyway
who does that
family i was glad you suffered for that
i was so annoyed i was so annoyed after
i say this i've got a question for you
by the way okay okay i was so annoyed
because i was on my way to work and
there's a marks and sparks right next to
my work i always tend to go in there to
grab like a juice or something to keep
me going depending on the shift i'm on
so i got this phone i got it two days
prior to actually when i used it because
i wanted to get a case i want to get a
screen protector i didn't want to [ __ ]
it up you know so i got all the uh
anomalies to make sure it was pound
so i was doing i did the whole challenge
we spoke about in the previous episode
where i transferred all my stuff from my
old phone to the new phone didn't even
know i didn't even know i could put the
tick next to each other a young
bluetooth ticker young infrared i didn't
even know so yeah um
my
all my data was obviously wiped off um
this new phone because it didn't have
the security didn't have the password
none of that so i went on to hsbc now
i knew
i knew before i left my yard that i had
to do it completely forgot completely
forgot
so this is me i think i got like a juice
and some sweets and something else i got
into the self-service till
i double tap my lock button they take it
locked
the thing didn't even come up with it
locked oh it locked i was like [ __ ] i
[ __ ] forgot but the one i had
activated was my monzo oh okay
i've got no p in the monzo and i can't
transfer money from my hsbc to my monzo
because my hsbc currently doesn't work
because i didn't actually set it up
because obviously a new phone i had to
set it all up again and i've forgotten
my username i've gotten all of that so
it's like i have pee but i can't access
it you're part of the poverty line now i
was part of the public i was getting
looked and walked all over yes looked at
and walked all over bro
bro you can't afford it get away from
self-service and i clicked again i was
like i was in a queue i tried to go on
hsbc and try and figure out how i
couldn't verify the thing i was like
this is too much pressure for me i don't
have time i don't have time for this so
i spoke to the lady at the that was
watching everyone out there self-service
like oh i just got a new phone and i've
been patting the thing so i'm gonna have
to leave the stuff here and i walked out
she must have been looking at me like
just saying you ain't got money do you
[ __ ] him just say you haven't got the
pee yeah just now i felt i felt so
embarrassed bro i felt so embarrassed
it's so annoying when technology doesn't
pattern when technology fails you bro
it's so annoying it happens to me today
um
obviously
on my way to see your barber yeah bro
listen to me
because i got i didn't even tell you
someone done a fraud thing on my card
you did tell me you told me last time
you were up yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
someone did a reporting on my card i
think you said that they sent me a new
card i did so yeah cause i was using
monzo
had sent me a new card
obviously all the card details are
different all my apps are set up to one
yeah yeah yeah my google like my parking
apps everything yeah all set up to the
same thing big man listen to me
obviously
parked up it's pissing down with rain ah
facing down rain so as i'm walking
towards the barbers yeah it's pissing
down with rain on my head i've got my
phone out like this and i'm trying to
pay for my parking on my parking app the
[ __ ] card details are wrong so i have
to update the car details i'm scurrying
to get my white out i've got the card
here i've got the phone here i'm walking
walking walking walking and i'm trying
to sort it out yeah the rain's dripping
all over my phone so the numbers are
putting in like three different numbers
at a time i'm getting vex throughout the
same time i need to go cash point to pay
for the haircut yeah big man walking
walking walking i'm trying to do this
thing get my card and put it in the cash
point the cash point didn't have any
money but the cash point wasn't saying
that it didn't have money oh so that you
go through the whole process
then it it will give you a call back and
say your cash is about to come out big
man no cash comes out so i'm sitting
there trying to [ __ ] with this stupid
thing i'm waiting for my cash there's
bare people behind me it's pissing down
with rain on my head i feel like i've
never been so angry
that's an annoying trifecta i don't
think it wears my mind yeah yeah and it
never came out so i had to step out
online open up my barclays
check like has it taken the money out of
my account and it took it out and then
reimbursed it and i'm still trying to
[ __ ] with this [ __ ] parking lot i'm
still looking for another atm bro i
could have
if someone would have been like
why are you taking so long so not even
that if someone would have been like
sorry have you got the time i would have
broken their jaw on the spot
that's an information i don't need
that's another added source i don't need
what's the date today i want to rock
them
on the floor i've never been so i've got
time for your questions blood red mad
fear
blood red mad bro my blood was hot ah
that's hilarious never been so vexed
that's hilarious oh so yeah this whole
technology thing family oh and it's been
[ __ ] with me because it's been what a
week two weeks mm-hmm a week and a bit
since i got my new card bro every time i
have to put in the car dude amazon yeah
flipping just eat roll deliver these
parking apps bro everything i have to
put these [ __ ] card details in and i
don't memorize them either i don't my
last card i knew the details off behind
it even if i had to put it in
done i knew the expiry i knew the
security code everything done bro this
new card is [ __ ] up my life i hate it
has it not automatically saved now
to some of them like the keychain thing
whatever yeah but some of them so it
goes when i do it on google chrome so if
i'm on if i'm doing something online
and then i'll do it
google will say like do you want to save
card details so you save it
but some
services online don't
connect to your google like that so when
you're going through the card details
sometimes you'll click it and it will
auto fill yeah and you can just bank
google scholar
bro they don't do it so i have to find
my wallet punch in the [ __ ] card
details it's just so long
in the scheme of things people are like
shut the [ __ ] up it takes 10 seconds but
at the time bro it is long everyone now
so far everyone knows what you're
talking about that happens to me a lot
but my saving grace is
i think a few years ago
maybe two and a half years ago like uh
christmas period for some reason i had
sent bella my card details
so my card details are still on our chat
so if i'm somewhat because like you said
i never take my wallet with me yeah yeah
yeah so if i need to pay for something
where google hasn't auto-automatically
uploaded my ting i just go on our
pictures
even though it's long i still have the
second option but i still have the
second option so i'm happy about that
cool
something
did you know then without martin sparks
thing
if you would have taken your stuff to
the normal till mm-hmm
if you have your card details they're
going to they can't stay in they're not
punching well to be fair
it's something i do know but it's not
something i thought about at the time i
wouldn't i would have panicked out i
wouldn't have thought about it yeah i
wouldn't have thought about i would have
panicked yeah because i know you can do
like manual yeah if the cashier doesn't
know that it's long
guys real quick you know the drill
it's time to take a quick pause and shed
some light on your boys over at manscape
these are the vibes they're helping your
guys
like your friends your family
they're helping them bust nuts on a
daily basis clap cheeks with a smooth
connective smooth connection yeah
no no no like what they call it brillo
brillo pad brillo pad yeah none of that
brillo pad thing that them days are over
um so obviously you already know what it
is let me just remind you one more time
guys it's the fourth generation thing
fourth generation 4.0 4.0 you've got
jeff bezos over here on your left along
with elon musk
and um what's the other guy's name from
virginia what's the billionaire's name
from richard branson richard branson all
these men are scrapping over technology
over here on the left yeah trying to get
into space yeah they're barely scraping
atmosphere
on your right hand side you've got your
boys at manscape helping over two
million men
clap cheeks
now
clearly we know where the better money
is being invested yeah
we know where the better money's being
invested and the scientists are over
here this is why these men can't reach
full space
because the real scientists they're in
the right in the labs they're in the
love when your boys get it in
so if you want that smooth groove that's
hilarious if you want that long schlong
um
head on over to manscape.com
the code is sng that's what you want to
type in big bad bat sng sierra never go
sierra
[Laughter]
sierra november goal that's the code and
that's going to give you a young a light
twenty percent off certain light
scientific yeah
yeah fighting something like trying to
dip your feet yeah yeah yeah just get
your toes wet with that 20
get yourself the perfect package 4.0
yeah that's going to get you all the
goodies it's going to get you
all the toners the deodorants them silky
smooth boxes boxes again wearing them
again today gang perfect boxes yeah man
and then
you you're gonna see when you hit that
pep in your step you're gonna realize
shit's different now shit's different
now um so heading on over there guys
it's manscape.com the code is sng and
you're going to get yourself free
shipping and 20 off head on over there
now pause the thing buy a package come
back back let's go back to the episode
okay
um but yeah bro oh i've got good news as
well okay fam maybe
last week in a bit
your boy's been in the gym dang
going last week i see you look at my arm
here
i see you glass down
last week in a bit you boys have been
training
i've needed it good like i said i've
needed at least a solid like four day
week for like months now three four five
six months bro i haven't had a four day
week probably in the last year
of like gym i did jim jim break jim jim
foo had i was sore yeah but in the best
way yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
i was sore in the best way fam
i love that i hit like i hit it because
i um i
signed up to a [ __ ] gym near me because
i wasn't making it into my proper gym
enough it's too far and the days that
i'm not like traveling into north and
stuff like that it's just not worth it
it's too long so um
on the days where i'm chilling at home
does the gym are signed up for it's like
20 pound a month it's like five minute
drive have you counseled the other gym
are you still being i'm doing both okay
for yeah i was going to do it but the
new gym is [ __ ] okay and i would be do
after a while i'd get depressed there
yeah so i want to use it as little as
possible but i still want to use it
so like my mondays and fridays now
that's my gym i go to the [ __ ] gym but
it's one of the ones where you forget
that like when you're in a [ __ ] gym and
you haven't got much equipment you have
to use your head a little bit more and
you have to really push
that equipment to the limit so when i
went on in their last monday
um i did
what did i do
i did legs and shoulders
bro i didn't move from the squat rack
for the whole session
leg shoulders and cardio for the whole
session i did front squats for like
eight sets
then i did
uh uh romania deadlifts for like eight
sets
then i did military press for like eight
sets
upright rows for eight sets all with the
barbell now
um and then i moved on and they did the
assault bike have you used the assault
bike before um probably once or twice
but not in a
not in
me and cardio fam me and cardio don't
don't [ __ ] with each other but separate
these i need to now i need to i'm
getting on
dirty now it doesn't fall off the way
it doesn't it really doesn't you used to
fall off
bro
that's hilarious over 30 you gotta work
for it
so i finished the session and i was like
gang i'm feeling good and i thought you
know [ __ ] it i'm doing like 10 minutes
on the assault bike but i just did like
i did tabata style so i did 20 seconds
on 10 seconds off
that you might have been drenched bro
you would have been dressed i was ruined
bro yeah i was wrecked especially after
legs bro especially i was a mess but
like i couldn't breathe but then by the
time i got my car i was so happy with
myself i love that had my protein
little little sprinkle of creatine in
there yeah fam i was like i'm a new man
i love it even bought my like my own tub
of pre-workout i usually buy pre-workout
at the gym i bought my own tub and i was
like
i need to get my [ __ ] together bro i'm
tired of it so last week or so it's been
a week in a bit now and i've been
hitting gym
consistently
i'm gonna struggle today and tomorrow
but whatever i'm i'm gonna need to get
four in a week no matter what i have to
do something four times a week
and hopefully i can move it back up to
five like the old days but that's
wishful thinking
but boy i got in there
and you can tell you've been at the game
a minute when you're not getting pumps
like you used to yep of course you're
just working out getting tired of course
because there's no pump bra of course
you're just knackered of course i'm
thinking do i even train yeah and then
come
thursday mm-hmm yeah they're just gone
does it just go yeah the boy was pumped
what did you work on i did chest triceps
and
chest triceps shoulders again calves and
cardio again oh wow that's a long
session
but the thing is the good thing about it
was i'm trying to keep it as short as
humanly possible so what i've been doing
is going in there just before work so i
start work at half four
i can get in there for like half two
mm-hmm
um but i found when i was doing it for
half time i was lollygagging in there
two hours to kill in the gym
lollygagging in there so the gym and
work are like two minute drive
so i went in there intentionally this
week
um came straight back from birmingham on
tuesday
straight to the gym got that half three
and i so i need to be out by like 20
past four to get to work on time um
so
yeah yeah i found banged it out
i've wrote down everything and i was
looking at thinking like i said i wrote
it all down and i was like this is going
to be a tight squeeze
but then i was going to take some stuff
out and i thought now [ __ ] it
go for it like try your absolute best to
get it all done
um and i i know that i'm only going to
be doing cardio for 10 minutes so as
soon as the clock hits doesn't matter
what i've decided like it doesn't matter
what set you're in doesn't matter how
many exercises you've done once you've
only got 10 minutes to go get upstairs
get on the cardio yeah go um and when i
did that on thursday fam
your boy was pumped um i had my hunter
hunter t-shirt on
gone
it was tight on the team and i was
thinking you know when you yeah yeah
straighten out your eyes you get the
tricep going yeah yeah your boy's
looking full yeah this is the old jimmy
yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm back in the cup
gang i was feeling good with dang i love
that worked up a sweat guy
i need to keep this going now i have to
i can't fall off again yeah man i want
to be the epitome of
wow
that's what i want chef's kids yeah next
summer yeah
i said it before i said it was going to
be this summer but it didn't work next
summer your boy's recording topless one
day one day breast out say less i'm here
for it say less gang man i'm happy for
you i'm happy because i've been slack
say i've been slacking i've been going
two three times a week and it's not
enough for me like i went
twice last week i did
shoulders
and i didn't chest and a bit of abs and
i felt great because the pump was good
it lasted like the shoulder pump lasted
a couple days the chest pop lasted a
couple days so i felt great that week
but i didn't do any lower half i didn't
do back i didn't do arms you know i
didn't do any secondary muscles and i
was like
yeah that's not it the week before i
think i only went twice and the week
before that yeah i think i only went two
or three times and there was a period of
time where i think there was a time
where i told you i've been training well
and every week i've tried not to miss
legs so every week every day i've got
off in the week i do legs i try and do
legs once one of my days off the week
just so i know i've got it out the way
because legs are one of my hardest legs
at the time or at a period of time was
one of my worst things to do yeah but
there were the time where i was there
was a time where i was doing it i did it
three times out of four in a month
and after the second or third time
it felt calm to me
it felt calm so i was getting used to it
so i need to get back into that again so
this week i'm gonna try and go three
times minimum hopefully four
to get myself back into it next week but
yeah guys enough about gym but obviously
yeah you've got your part time now in it
yes yes so surely he's got a pattern
yeah i said last week just gone i just
relished at my part-time yeah of course
i relished in my course when i first
quit my job for two weeks i didn't do
anything yeah so your boy's gone down to
four days a week now guys so i'm slowly
i'm so it's a mini announcement i'm
slowly getting into the position where i
can remove myself from hospitality and
work full-time on this so your boy's
working four days now and three days
he's got to himself so it's benefiting
me
well bro i bet well bro
the thirds i had off i told you what
shang chi the movie the movie's good
i've heard it the movie's good i need to
see it bro maybe he's good i need to i
don't know
if you don't watch it either this week
or next you're not going to watch it
yeah i'm going to miss it i'm done it's
been a month and a half now it's done i
know it's done it's done um but it's one
of those ones where
i already know the second one's going to
be better i already know what else he
will be involved in will be better oh
but it's a good start okay it's a good
because it's the first one it's like
captain america yeah the first one for
me wasn't the best but you know he's a
sh he's a solid
avenger you know yeah yeah he's a guy
all right so he's gonna be one of them
in my opinion all right calm but yeah my
your boy's been relishing in the time
off saturday
me and bella was both me and better had
saturday off we didn't move james
we watched football all day
all the chinese at night she napped you
in the evening
we
chilled bro
and i was like i've not done this in god
knows how long gang love that god knows
how long gang loved that so for me it
was a breath of fresh air i bet and
obviously this week we're recording
today and i've got two other days off
this week so i'm gonna definitely
definitely work out definitely train and
just get my [ __ ] together man let's go
but yeah man um
i'm happier now i'm gonna i'm in a
better space now i feel like i'm
part-time because i'm low-key
give me a few more months i can maybe
drop down to three days i mean we have
four days i'll join this three-day club
bro i need it i'm not going up you
couldn't pay me to do four days oh i i
need you to pay me
i did four days last week and i want to
knock someone out
three days is where am i it changes
everything it does the extra day changes
everything in your case extra two days
my extra day changes i'm trying to go
down to two days oh that's what i need
uh i would say two months i'm going down
to two days i would love that they have
to i have to bro you guys make it happen
for us man if you want that juicy
content because this the thing is
obviously we talk about this a lot but
the stuff we actually have planned for
this show
once we get to that position
bro you man are going to get content
bro you man are going to get content
yeah
this whole world as well this whole move
to um
to birmingham yeah yeah like
probably people don't know that we're
moving studios so we can produce more
content yeah that's the whole reason
we're doing it doesn't benefit us in any
other which way we're literally only
doing it so we can produce more content
for you guys um so we're excited man so
yeah shit's gonna start looking up it's
gonna start looking real nice
i'm excited gang so i'm ig all right
i've got a question for you
actually i've got two questions for you
i don't know which one i asked in this
episode i might ask both i might not
we'll see how long this one takes so i
asked myself this question
in the shower a few days ago yeah i
don't know why actually i do know why
and i asked bella yesterday and it made
her think so i want to ask you
um
at this current moment
you guys can answer as well or have a
think in the audience or the listeners
viewers etc
what three things right now make you
happy
what three things making me happy
guys have a think as well what three
things right now make it up you don't
you don't have to rush it
obviously you've been
we can chop and check we could dice up
the phone it's gonna be for like
three things make me happy
playstation go
makes me very happy
tell you what actually makes me happy
hit me
support
okay this sounds corny
it doesn't but continue support because
it makes me happy sorry to cut you off
there because everyone's happiness is
different and everyone's circumstances
are different so you know what makes you
happy in your certain current lifestyle
right now so i don't think
because i know you i know for a fact it
doesn't sound silly yes i know what you
mean because you know where i'm coming
from exactly you're the place i'm coming
from exactly and you know how hard it
sometimes is to get support exactly and
yeah yeah continue yeah cool yeah
support from obviously like my household
yeah uh family and obviously friends and
all that stuff is a big
it makes me very happy because yeah like
i said like
there's been times where i've not felt
very supported
in just everyday life yeah and it's
tough bro it can take a strain on you of
course and it's
unprovoked support that makes me happy
makes sense
um
like when i told you when we spoke on
friday
yes and i was struggling now yes yes yes
yes
yes and then out of nowhere i'm getting
support yes um
so yeah that was good
so playstation
support yeah i'm writing these down by
the way and what else makes me happy
um
productivity makes me happy okay
i
found when i have a day so you see these
days that you said um
like you and better just chilled and
napped and watched football and all that
stuff
like
i love those days
but only if
i feel i've had a very productive like
week leading up to that
so the days where i
so for example
obviously like i said i have to drive
home from manchester tonight
i'm not gonna get home until like
probably one or two o'clock in the
morning and i'm probably gonna have to
get up about seven
to get on what i need to do tomorrow
so once i've got some of the stuff once
i've got the essential [ __ ] out the way
tomorrow yeah i'm gonna wanna kip i'm
gonna want to keep for the whole day
but i've got [ __ ] to do tomorrow yeah so
if i can manage to because so i know
tomorrow regardless if i get five hours
sleep two hours late whatever i know for
a fact tomorrow
if i
go back to bed at like nine o'clock ten
o'clock
and then sleep until like three
whenever
i'm gonna be
so annoyed because it's a day of [ __ ] i
just i've done nothing i've literally
done nothing for a whole day okay
and then like where most people were
like oh gang i'd love to be able to just
go home and sleep the morning away
if if i don't feel productive
big man i would rather
literally
i would rather get home
at two o'clock in the morning
open my laptop and work until five
and then sleep the day and then or stay
awake until seven or whatever and then
sleep all day and then i would feel like
i deserved that sleep yeah because
you've done something because i was
productive i got what i needed to do
done and more so and all the the the
eyes are dotted and the t's are crossed
and now i can rest
when i'm resting and i don't feel like
i've earned it i want to kill myself and
i get lit i physically feel depressed
because i'm just like what am i even
doing yeah i'm wasting my life away yeah
i feel that way times where
i've um
i've either worked like a long shift or
worked like a night shift or like a
close shift rather
and i wake up the next day i'm off i've
worked the next day i'm off the next day
and i'm just knackered in bed and i'm
saying to myself all right today i'm
going to train i'm going to do this i'm
going to do that i'm going to do that
i'm going to do that i'm going to meal
prep
and for example like that saturday just
gone it wasn't that day that i felt that
way but for example we did nothing all
day so if it was one of those days where
i plan to do this and i end up doing the
complete opposite i'm like i should have
contacted jim yeah bro i should have
gone to the gym because the the not
doing what you wanted to do
never feels as good as you think it's
going to be a hundred percent bro 100 it
feels good at that moment or at that
time when you're knacking and blah blah
blah but you already know the pump you
could have gone from the gym or the
satisfaction you could have felt from
doing a couple edits here doing a couple
clips there you know doing whatever you
need to do to tick off the list bro like
boom this has been a good day the tick
off the list feeling the days where i've
woken up had breakfast
edited
um done whatever emails that we need to
do and all that stuff then had more than
enough time to like eat a proper lunch
go to the gym
have a proper gym session then if i'm
working that evening going to work with
some form of energy yeah come home eat
and then it's it's bedtime or or
playstation time fam
i feel like a winner yeah i think i've
achieved [ __ ] today yeah i [ __ ]
achieve [ __ ] today i feel amazing like
whereas if i'm like
oh i'm too knackered to go gym there's
no point in that space if i'm supposed
to go gym from two and three and i'm
like oh i'm too knackered to go gym
when i've decided i ain't going gym i
don't look at my clock at half two and
think thank [ __ ] i'm not at the gym
right now i never feel that feeling i
never feel like oh i'm so happy i'm here
rather than the gym i'm just lazy in
there i'm not feeling good about
anything i'm just lazy yeah and it's not
i don't feel good order feel bad i'm
just like a vegetable yeah yeah and then
once i've realized that time has passed
i'm like because eventually apart from
that saturday usually for me
eventually i'm gonna have to get up and
do something okay yeah and then once
you've once you are up and you're doing
stuff you think
i should have just gone to the gym 100
because it was no issue getting up 100 i
just couldn't be bothered and now that
i'm actually up and i'm dressed i'm
showered and i'm almost done i think i
should have just gone yeah yeah i hate
being unproductive bro being productive
makes me feel great it makes me feel
great cool so what did i say playstation
playstation support family and
productivity okay part two with a
question okay
what and some of the answers can be the
same all right what three things would
make you happier
oh
probably everything i just said with the
word more next to it
more playstation more support more
productivity um what three things would
make me happier mm-hmm
more financial stability
financial stability will make me happier
okay
all right then because money doesn't
make me happy
the stability of having the money making
but when i've had money
like more money than i need
whatever short bouts they are and
there's no reason for me to spend it at
this moment in time
i i can i just breathe easier bro you
wake up nice
like
when you get letters for your letterbox
and you're not concerned about opening
them it's a nice feeling when you've got
letters and you think i don't even want
to know what this is yeah yeah i don't
even want to know what this is
it could be from anyone fam anyone in
anything that's hilarious yeah i know
that's right
you can't deal with that stress yeah um
yeah so more financial stability will
make me happier
um
i don't think more support i feel i feel
quite happy with the support right now
um
definitely more consistent productivity
will
like more productivity will make me
happier a million percent if i could get
those feelings literally every day i'll
be so
happy um
so what's the third thing that will make
me happier
just more alone time more free time
that's it
more free time more productivity and
more financial stability cool those
three things make me happy happy cool
um the reason why i asked this question
is because i wanted to see if the three
things that make you happy and the three
things that will make you happier are
interlinked yeah yeah um i'm gonna tell
you what i said to myself the reason why
i asked myself this question was because
every time i shower i listen to music
and music makes me happy yeah music
changes my state of mind regardless of
what feeling i'm feeling
and it's it does something to me you
know okay and i love music and at that
current time i think i was listening to
afrobeats afrobeats is my first love
it's my first i can't help it it's in my
genes you know it's my first love
so i was listening to thinking
this just fills me with joy so i asked
myself the question my my answers were
what makes me happy
are music
um i said friends and family in like one
bracket and
the last thing i said was
um
what was the last thing i said
oh i said the podcast oh okay i said um
so this makes me happy music
friends and family and the podcast and i
said what three things would make me
happier
i think music and family and friends are
a constant so i can't change i couldn't
change that because they're always going
to make me happy so i left those two but
the third thing i said was free time
that was the third one i did i was
thinking
am i how are they related obviously
doing the podcast
and free time in a sense are related
because
by doing this podcast in mic or in our
current situation ie i've got another
job
i am trying to find a way to create more
free time for
the productivity in this podcast to make
me happier yeah so
when i say free time i don't necessarily
mean i'm gonna have five days off of
work two days because that's not free
time yeah well that is free time but
it's not the free time i'm talking about
it's the sense of
being able to put all my energy and
effort into what i am passionate about
which currently makes me happy which is
the podcast which will inevitably give
me more free time to work on the podcast
yeah so that's how the two were
interlinked for me so the reason why i
asked you because i wanted to see if
your two were interlinked so i'm
definitely into you're definitely
interlaced because as soon as you said
uh so your your first three are ps5
support and productivity that will make
you happy but on the other side won't be
happier is financial stability
consistent productivity and free time
so i feel like
productivity in itself
productivity for me answers all of them
all of those three questions yeah
product me being productive will enable
me to be more productive which will
enable me to have more financial
stability which will
give me more free give you more free
time and that's the reason why i asked
this question because i wanted the
audience or the listeners and the
viewers to think as well like is are you
at a stage in your life where
you are currently happy about certain
things but what things could make you
happier and if you could be happier
which i feel like everyone could be
are you making the right choices in life
are you
taking the correct steps to make
yourself happier or do you know what's
going to make you happy but you're not
actually doing anything about it that's
the reason why i asked the questions i
got deep in it that's the reason why i
asked the question that's very good bro
bro hundred
hundred
100
i don't do this [ __ ] in my life that's
going to make me happier yeah
i don't do it i think a lot of people do
i like we've spoken about already like
there are days where we're just lazy the
gym makes me happy bro the [ __ ] that i
do productivity things that make me
happy the [ __ ] that i do
that when i'm feeling lazy
i tell myself not to do
and i don't do it and it just incurs
more unhappiness yeah
when i actually do them bro i feel so
much better and the other day i was
stressing i was flustered about all the
[ __ ] i needed to do and i wanted to do
none of it bro
and i needed to make a clip i needed to
edit a clip at least one
and i need i really needed to do about
four or five i was a couple days behind
yeah because we were recording and then
something else happened and then
something else happened i was like four
or five days behind about doing a couple
clips and then i was like right i need
to do like five clips tomorrow i was
like i ain't gonna have time bro yeah
i'm working in the morning i've got this
and that and i'm not gonna have to do
five so i was speaking to um
aaron on the phone and he was like bro
just do all you can do in it but don't
stress about this fighting just do two
and that's more productive you're gonna
be more productive if you just do one or
two and actually have a smooth
transition throughout the day where you
get everything done that's more
productive day than stressing saying i
need to do this you just need to do this
and you're flustered and you get hardly
anything done as to the goal that you've
set yourself which is unachievable in
the first place yeah then you feel like
you've had an unproductive day yeah just
do what's possible and you'll feel
satisfied at the end of the day bro
i thought cool i'm gonna do two yeah i'm
gonna do two
did all my work did the two clips
uploaded one of the clips of tiktok
stayed viral a young 1.5 million views
satellite it's not a fault a young
tender 1.5 yeah bro
and i was like
gang gang yeah
gang because if i didn't speak to him
and stayed with my same mindset i said
i've got five to do i would have happily
written the week off but i'm just not
gonna do any this week i can't i would
have been like i can't handle this level
of stress i'm not gonna do anything i'm
just gonna like sink into my own little
hole yeah i wanna be left alone i'm
gonna turn my notifications off and i'm
just gonna play playstation until i fall
asleep yeah yeah i just want to be left
alone bro but the whole thing of like
breaking it down right this is what i
need to do
let's just do that
see what happens
um and then
felt good afterwards even before it did
it did well i felt gang like this this
is nice that's just chill
um
and yeah man those productive days bro
they make you feel so much happier of
course without a shadow so much happier
so much happier oh i just need them
every day i want i literally want to
feel like that every day because then
those days are also the days where it's
like
i also feel like being productive
doesn't mean
working yourself to death either
because
the days where i felt most rewarded
at the end of those days i'll check the
time and i've got time to do like a
full-blown dinner if i want to
like a big boy dinner
and i'm thinking what a day yeah what a
day i've done all this stuff and it's
only six o'clock
i've got there's there's food in the
fridge like let's let's go out let's
make a dinner dinner
you've got time to chill in the evening
and everything as well
the days that i'm working so hard and
then i look up and i see it's like one
o'clock in the morning and i'm still
doing [ __ ] i don't feel good after those
days
regardless if i've done a lot of [ __ ] i
don't feel good those days i'm just like
what because you tried to fit everything
in one i've tried to fit a year and a
day yeah and it's just killing me the
days that you just take bite-sized
chunks and just take little steps
forward the small wins throughout the
day and you get like 10 small wins and
you're just like
what a day now i can actually turn off
my brain and actually just watch
something or read something or do
something and i'll just like
not think yeah i don't have to think bro
my phone can be vibrating i air it but
those days where i'm unproductive but if
my phone starts vibrating my phone
literally just vibrates
with my friends vibrate i'm stressed
mm-hmm because i'm thinking what have i
[ __ ] forgotten now or what what when
he's doing this and i'm just like ugh i
can't handle it see ya man right i think
i've answered myself i need to be more
productive i need to be more every
single this wasn't for me to make you
realize what you needed to do it was
just a generic question oh no yeah but
yeah it's made me realize regardless
hopefully you guys at home listen of you
and have thought of your three answers
for both and it's made you realize
something as well so yeah that's the
reason why i asked gang that's cool man
before we go before we go inside now a
quick segue you just spoke about ps5
mandem galdem i've been trying to score
ps5 for a year now
ps5 has been out for a year
still can't get it anywhere oh [ __ ] i
still can't get if you guys know any
legit sites i don't want no [ __ ]
wasteman one legit sites drop me a link
because i need to buy it bro you know
i've been trying to buy it for ages you
should have told me that before now i
swear
you should have told me that before now
just yesterday oh my god
a couple days ago i got my
email from curry's yeah
my vip email said you can buy a ps5
and i forwarded it to someone else
yesterday
that's annoying if you were told me you
were on the hunt for a ps5 i would have
sent it to you that's annoying
it's a shame his ways
his ways
i've told the world now so
hopefully i get 15 emails or dm's yeah
yeah sure
i'm waiting on it sorry g is ways i've
waited a year without yourself what's
another day
have you seen this high life ting the
work high life
it's basically made in chelsea but black
people yes i've seen an advert for it so
it's rich african
um
like children like the pet the children
of rich african parents
yes and no um so i've only seen that
ever for us so i've seen a dj dj copy
and um two or three other people like
high-end influencers
um and they
in a lot of aspects like [ __ ] okay but
i'm not a big reality tv guy anyway okay
so i'm always gonna think of [ __ ] okay i
think most of reality tv is [ __ ] i don't
like
curated conversations between people
they annoy me bro so when i'm watching a
conversation
you already know it's not and i know
it's not legit it's scripted i'm just
like get me off this thing um
some of it's interesting
the characters are interesting so like i
break down the characters and some of
them are interesting and some of them
are like oh okay
um so obviously like you said yeah it's
all like
london-based
nigerians and ghanaians
um
most of them are caked
living in london
only
from what i've seen only three of them
have rich parents
so one don his name's kid
his dad's a billionaire
[Music]
kid is a waste man oh really
i'm gonna throw it out there
kid is a waste man oh my dad you've
managed to fight with a t waste man and
he's waste man
he's a waste man he's
so unintelligent
oh like street smart saw in
general just in terms of right
like he tries to say profound [ __ ] okay
i'm looking at the cast while you're
talking by the way yeah yeah yeah yeah
he tries to say profound [ __ ] and really
struggles he's the richest out of all of
them
um
and
like he just just he's just dumb bruv
he's just dumb like there's so many
examples so you just like bro you're
just dumb
like um
what so what what has he done that's
dumb okay cool so in the trailer yeah in
the advert breaks they ask each of them
like when did you what that was one
question when did you find your voice
and they all give different answers
no no no no no no they ask a different
one like not
not when did you find your voice that's
one of the questions there's another one
just about like um
where do you f like where do you get
your knowledge from what's up i don't
know what the question is you only
really understand because they don't he
and basically on the advert
you don't hear the question you just
hear their answers of course so unless
they repeat the question you don't know
what that question is there's one thing
where he's talking about his life
experiences and growing up all over the
world and he's like yeah like i've
learned so much like i've i've grown up
literally all over the world
his examples foohat
he's like
nigeria
the uk
london in the uk mm-hmm
the next thing he says
kent
kent kent
nigeria uk he's got that's warlords
london
kent
shrewsbury
he says all over the world and he says
nigeria and then basically he says
england three times yeah
he's thick brother
and he always is the son of the
billionaire this is the son of a
billionaire and he always says
[ __ ] that's just like you're damn brave
like you're done
and you don't realize that you're dumb
and no one else around you is telling
that you're down
and like um there was one he was having
a conversation with um the carpeting
yeah
and
she's trying to explain to him
why he's acting up like he he's just
acting different brother
and then he flips on her and says well
maybe if such and such i don't want to
spoil it but basically says like maybe
if you weren't so xyz
you'd probably be able to keep a man
but when i say the conversation they had
had so far from anything to do with her
and men
that it was just like
raw it's basically like me having a
conversation with you now and you'll be
like oh james like
you're kind of spending your money
frivolously like
it's looking a bit peak yeah like relax
and i turned around and was like well
big man if you weren't maybe if you
stopped
trying to give people advice your mom
would love you more
do you know
it's so west too far in between yeah
yeah she was like
what she picked up a drink dashed at him
said what dash that i'm walked off so i
don't need to hear this [ __ ] yeah and
then he tried to justify himself to one
of his virgins and his prejudice was
just like
are you crazy
are you crazy and it actually took
people to like sit him down and explain
to him
why that was a bad thing for him to say
okay in order for him to be like oh
right i get it but he's so thick
he's so thick
and he
uh
he uh
he annoys me bro and he's gasps because
he created his own cocktail
okay
but like
obviously a cocktail is just drink i i
thought he when when he was bringing up
his cocktail like i've i've got this
cocktail and it's doing really well in
nigeria i want to bring it to the uk
market all this stuff i was expecting to
bring him he was going to have his own
vodka his own something his own special
i thought he was the way he was bigging
it up i thought he was going to have
something special
fam he just went behind the bar and made
it himself
so he's using like other people's
residues
vodka yeah and stan and fam
and he's guessing he held his own party
to celebrate his release of his his own
what was the drink called do you
remember or what yeah i do remember it's
called kid on the rocks
kid on the rocks what was in it do you
remember i remember there's four shots
of vodka that's all i remember that's
all i remember because when he was doing
it the yat who worked for the restaurant
that he was pitching it to was like four
what
did you see my face yeah yeah yeah fam
she did not like the taste of it either
she took a sip and she was like and he
was like what do you think she was like
uh strong takes a minute for you to
really
adjust to the the strength of it
um but yeah frank he gets guest of it
and you're just like man he needs
someone in his corner to say your
brother no offense you're an idiot
but
one thing that resonates with me with
him
is that i feel he's paying he
longs for his dad's like approval
he longs for it who had he
longs for it so he's trying to like do
business stuff by himself and he's just
bought a house in london with his own
money
[Music]
props and they were talking they were
asking them about oh like is your dad
gonna he was like yeah my dad's supposed
to come
and visit me today and we're gonna have
a chat i haven't seen him in a few
months and i'm looking forward and he
kept making jokes like he's obviously
just gonna come in here
and like tear this pace to shreds he'll
probably like spend like half an hour
here and then um go to like a hotel down
the road or something like he won't want
to be in here for long and the house was
nice i can't afford the house yeah yeah
yeah yeah um the house was banging but
he was like yeah my dad would just think
like what are you doing but hopefully he
respects like
the fact that i'm trying to do stuff by
myself and i was thinking i feel you bro
and then like 10 minutes later he sits
down he's like oh it turns on my dad's
not coming
can make it i get it he's busy and i'm
thinking oh
that stings
that stings
that does thing bro it's peak so there's
him
there's the dj copy
[Music]
um
there's a bit where she she makes a song
with doneo in it
i don't know
in the in the show in the show she makes
a song with danaya she's like and
donaire's like i want you singing on the
thing and she's like oh i've been like
slated before for my singing voice and
all that stuff like i'm not confident
he's like be confident like you got
beautiful voices so fine fam her voice
is shocking i'm not surprised she's a
terrible dj as well so
shocking dj
yeah
her voice is [ __ ] [ __ ] i was howling
but she's cool um
and then
there's these sisters
fam this is one yet called banisha
body i didn't say that rehearsal yeah
yeah i can imagine
disgraceful body yeah disgraceful but
face is banging as well yeah but the
disgraceful body you
you know my face my face will be like
already if i see that yeah yeah yeah i
already know i already know the vibes i
would say watch the show just for that
yeah her body's disgusting bruh it's
disgusting
yeah
yeah i heard people need to talk to our
people yeah and
figure saturn out she's got disgrace
she is a flirt
there's this one jeweler um brown there
what's his name
chifa okay yeah he obviously shots
jewelry and he sells story to them a lot
okay he's part of the show he's just
part of the show he's part of the show
um but he doesn't come from so that
benicio yeah her and her sisters are in
it they don't come from wealth okay but
they come from a piece of wealth okay
same with chifa he doesn't come from
wealth but he made his own design okay
so they the girls they made their own
they made their money from beauty they
have their own shop and stuff like that
but they come when i say when it comes
from a piece of welfare because their
dad bought their shop for them it was
like 25k he invested at 25k into their
business
yeah yeah yeah yeah
um
and the chief of bread i i think he did
everything by himself to be fair um as
far as i know and then there's another
guy
on there and his wife they get married
on there the wife is jamaican she's the
only jamaican person but she's the only
non-african in the whole show
and there's a guy in his face he comes
from [ __ ] money he's a producer he
comes from [ __ ] money bruh he comes
from [ __ ] money bruv
somebody's mad at this thing he actually
comes from money yeah the kids he does
think he has a governor yeah the kid
rare comes from money and um
this i think his name's
tommy okay money him and his sisters
money
money
um
and the thing is they do well for
themselves career-wise yeah but they
come from money and you're just like
it's just easier for you man of course
it's just easier for you man's rocking
around driving if i can ask the martin
luther bentley
and like obviously great i know you're a
producer and that's great and like one
of his sisters is an author and all this
stuff and they're talking about all
these great things but you just know for
a fact that like shit's just easier for
you though yeah yeah yeah it's just
easier for you bro there's no denying it
it just is
like um yeah they come from money from
money
their yard is massive
um
and um
what else was it someone i'm sure
someone said on there that they've got
like
three nannies or some [ __ ] however
there's a lady out she said she's got
like a team of three nannies are helping
her out on some [ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up
this is a joke
um
yeah that might come from money
tony i'm not
tommy sorry his sisters banging as well
yeah both his sister's banging yeah both
of his sisters are banging swear i might
have to watch this yeah yeah you have to
yeah benisha yeah and the two
tommy's two sisters banging
all three of them are banging say no
more um
but yeah the show's interesting yeah
like it's all right i wouldn't recommend
it to people but is it interesting like
i've been watching it because like when
i'm
at like dinner time and [ __ ] when i'm
eating food i can't get into stuff i
just want to be zoned out i just want to
watch easy [ __ ] i just want to put on
like some come down with me or something
bro so i thought let me stop on this
highlighting
um
and yeah it's an interesting watch but
it made me realize as well
for
one we're in a weird space in time
where obviously you know where people
obviously people want to be
self-represented yeah and build their
own businesses and stuff like that
fam
uh
the amount of times you hear
the term like my brand
my brand or like
this empire i'm trying to build i'm
trying to build my brand or i'm trying
to represent this and
it's just so like
overused and like so like is this all we
care about anymore and just like
i find we we fall into it a lot but
obviously we're boys so we don't have to
talk about that but obviously we have
these discussions about this like
getting rich discussions and all this
stuff which everyone does
but like on this show that's all you
don't hear about there's not a single
conversation on this show that's not
revolved around coming up
there's not a round of
revolved around chase in the bag no
one's just like yo like
what'd you eat for breakfast like no one
has a normal conversation bro there's
obviously um tommy and his business are
getting married so they speak about
wedding [ __ ] but apart from that bro
every single conversation is
my parents they moved over here they
came from nothing i'm trying to do this
they worked so hard so i could live a
certain way i'm trying to build my brand
and and like set generations ahead of me
so they don't have the ending that's all
it is bro
constantly no one has a normal
conversation anymore
and then
it made me realize like that's just how
people talk now yeah to everyone
like it's always like oh i've got this
little side business that i'm trying to
do this and that's all people ever talk
about which regardless of where you are
in the spectrum of the grind everyone
talks about that that's what all people
talk about yeah it's the grinder and
just like
i don't know i felt like when i was
watching i was thinking this is so
boring now like it's all well and good
but at the same time just do what you're
doing yeah but just have conversations
with people you don't have to fit in
your [ __ ] brand every two seconds
like people know what you do yeah and
even in the normal conversations like
people are like oh yeah yeah she's
coming up man like she's doing the thing
like even like there's a flirty flirty
moment where the jeweler chief has said
on a watch to benicia the painting
they're flirting
they're flirting and even the flirting
has to come down to like i see you
obviously you've been grinding and
you're doing your thing and you're
coming up and you're just like you just
what else though yeah you ever just talk
normal though yeah like why would we
have to talk about it it's a bit saucy
yeah what is this yeah uh it's so
annoying bro and it's taken me to watch
this show to realize how like
what i'm watching is so
annoying to listen to but it's just it's
actually normal in everyday life as well
like i have these conversations of
obviously you and our boys and stuff
like that i do feel like though
i'm grateful that
us as friends we don't have those
conversations all the time we hardly
ever have this conversation to be fair i
haven't reviewed when we're talking
business [ __ ]
having with aaron
a lot of the time but in terms of like
us as groups and all this stuff this is
not really stuff we're talking we're
just chat yeah yeah i'm just thinking
people are losing the art of just
chatting
like people just can't chat anymore it
always has to be business related it
wasn't to be like
it's starting to do a chase in the back
no matter what it is it's starting to do
chase in the back it's just boring now
bro um
so yeah i don't know if you've
recommended watching it watch the show
for the tings bro
what's the show for the things the rest
of it's [ __ ] yeah you're intriguing
me so i might watch an episode or two
and see what it's about but um i was
kind of following up from that show or
following up from you talking about the
show
do you know the double entendre of why
it's called high life
no
okay so high life is a very popular
ghanaian which is western african
music genre
and obviously high life the show is
about living high and living high and
it's based on nigerians
so that's the double entendre of white
interesting second segue about the show
you were talking about what was the
guy's name that made the cocktail or
kids made the cocktail kid so
did you know or do you know that the guy
that um
created the porn star martini his name
is douglas ankara
hughes ghanaian how was it yeah he
unfortunately died this year i've met
him twice coincidentally this was back
when i was working in um
food well oh okay um he randomly walked
in this was in manchester he randomly
walked in and we were randomly having a
conversation and then he told me oh yeah
i could i don't know how he got into
that i was going to say i don't know how
he got into it i can't remember the
conversation
i mean i think he was sitting on his own
i was waiting for someone or something
and he was like uh yeah i created the
porn star my team i was like sweat swear
down because i've known about the porn
star martini ever since i've been in
hospitality yeah of course i've been in
hospitality you know that's probably one
of the most popular drinks in the world
when it comes to
cocktails yeah yeah yeah everyone it's a
staple drink i was thinking
you did what so for me it was like i'm
meeting someone that did that
plus your ghanaian
plus i didn't even know like
i didn't think i didn't even know people
made the drinks i thought people just
came into a room collectively and like
you put this i didn't know how it worked
you know it went at like the g4 summit
exactly i thought the world leaders
made some [ __ ] together is it right this
tick tick tick all right let's give out
to the people how do you make a drink
and then
actually be like okay this is what it's
gonna be how do you
plug it
fam i don't know basically i guess
that's what this kid used doing just
plug it like yeah you have to get a
pattern on it obviously and then
trademark the thing and
how you plug it this this drink is i
don't know if it's worldwide but this
drink is what's on martinis worldwide i
don't know i've never seen them i've
never used worldwide ordered or thought
to order i don't even order
possibilities but i've never thought to
go to a bar and see if they do on
somebody's abroad you know
i know in the uk and you everywhere
doesn't every everywhere does this is he
british
he's british yeah yeah he's british but
he's obviously gunning
and british yeah oh i was like wow mad
how old is he
um he
died when he was
he was born in 1970 2021 so 51. okay
gang that's cool man
yes it's wild bro that's very very cool
that's very very cool
because that
like if you had created a a cocktail
that no not that many people unless you
work in that kind of field or you
specialize in bartending
for like a hemingway daiquiri have you
heard of hemingway daiquiri no exactly i
have not exactly so for you it might not
even seem that
gang not a porn star martini the fact
that was great by a guy as well yeah
it's such a popular female drink
fam which is a great thing to do they
always plug when you plug for the female
market and they suck it up literally
yeah bro yeah you're gone you're okay
bro he's clear
clear clear but yeah i thought i thought
it was pretty cool to meet him the time
i did it was like two three years ago
now before it was really dope that's
very cool i would love to meet someone
that just that says something like oh
yeah i invented the porn star martini
i'm like
i that doesn't make sense yeah i don't
understand what you're saying
break it down yeah it's like saying i
invented the hoover
what do you mean
what do you mean
that doesn't make sense to me literally
doesn't make sense oh but yeah that was
jokes but
it one thing it made me realize is
actually like watching the show anything
like that obviously
i know you men who are like obviously
africans
and a lot of people i know are africans
and i know a lot of caribbean people as
well
and i i i'm i'm
scratching the surface of like a big
difference and how that applies how the
difference in mentality applies to
the different cultures between caribbean
people and african people okay in what
sense in that so as you're watching it
basically as you're watching it as
you're watching the show and stuff like
that and both like the nigerians and the
ghanaians and stuff that they come over
and like quite a few of their parents
came with nothing bro so the benicia
yeah her dad came as a refugee from
ghana
um that's nothing nothing yeah that's
that's nothing nothing yeah and then an
eye number bro yeah that's nothing
nothing so he came up up yeah started
his own business and things like that
and like
i feel like
basically obviously africans are hard
working yeah you man are hard working
the [ __ ] that you tell me you do
sometimes and i'm just like i'm just not
gonna do it yeah i'm just not gonna do
it
don't care yeah um i just feel like the
mentality between
behind like africans a lot of the time
when it comes to work and success
is just like
give me the blueprint
tell me what i need to do to be rich
yeah and i'll do it yeah and i'll do it
better and harder than anyone has done
it because i'm trying to be i'm trying
to be rich yeah
and you might work
um
and then you take caribbean people yeah
and they're just like
look at the blueprint look at you just
shrug their shoulders
how much
how much you're going to be making
tomorrow uh tomorrow you're not going to
be making nothing but you need
you lost me man you've lost me yeah
what's the holiday package look like
it's just this is looking like a lot
but like
i realized like obviously watching them
man yeah and how they grinded and how it
was like it went they went from the the
literal blueprint yeah like you do this
like my barber's a good example so you
take an african person right and you
give him the blueprint he's from
zanzibar yeah yeah so you take it you
take this is like my bob is like a prime
example of how i hear everything
in terms of african people that come to
england right yeah yeah they come on
over yeah
um they get a job
and then you man just have the blueprint
of cool i get a job i make this much
money once i've got this much money i
can do this this this this and this and
then when you get an african person who
comes from nigeria ghana or zanzibar or
anywhere they come on over
they they they get some money doing a
[ __ ] job they open a shop in whatever
niche that they're in
you check in on them in 10 to 15 years
they've got four farms in nigeria
they're living lavish yeah yeah yeah
yeah but they're still working
um like for example like mobile is a
prime example he's got businesses in
africa businesses yeah but he still
works in the shop yeah yeah yeah that's
standard that's normal
yeah yeah that's standard for you man i
always hear it and then eventually you
pack your bags and you go back to africa
and you live lavish forever yeah that's
the blueprint yeah and you man always do
it yeah and you always have and i think
it's sick
but then i'm realizing like so how do
like
caribbean people make money then
because we're just not willing to do
that
more time we're just not willing to do
it yeah um that's hilarious
because for one we're just not um
for one yeah we're not that hard working
we are hard working in some aspects but
we're just not comparison though we're
not willing to just like
mindlessly work towards the aim okay
you're just too lazy for that yeah just
want to chill yeah yeah yeah yeah and
then i look at my brother
and my dad yeah my brother
is the
best possible example of how you take
lazy ingenuity and turn it into money
okay
my brother literally
gets paid
because people give him jobs to do
and he says in his head
that's long broth i'm not doing that
yeah so he figures out a way
to create some kind of program
or automated system
that he just doesn't have to do that
brav okay do you know what i mean yeah
how is he patting that though coding oh
sick just coding okay he learnt coding
by himself
wow he learned coding by himself and now
in his job but i was at his i was i was
at his um
i was at his yard a few weeks ago i
don't know if i told you that was that a
few weeks ago and he had to do something
they had like an end of month like
reporting or stuff too he had to fill
out like something ridiculous like 36
different spreadsheets big boy
spreadsheets it was going to take him
weeks to do it
so we clocked the ting and it was
literally like cool i could spend the
next eight hours a day for the next two
weeks filling out these [ __ ] boring
spreadsheets or
i can spend four days figuring out how
to code a system that's going to do
these spreadsheets for me
and then literally i was there towards i
must have been i must have got there on
day four yeah because as i'm in his room
like i was on my laptop and i looked up
and he was like ready i need each one
and then like press enter and the fam
the ting was doing minority report
things the thing was just popping up
with windows
and he was like cool now i don't have to
do these [ __ ] spreadsheets the
system's just gonna do the spreadsheets
for me and it's like that's the best
example of someone being [ __ ] lazy
i think i'm not doing that anything you
give my brother is that no no no i need
to there's no there must be a easier way
to do this i'm not doing that and just
make profit from it
because
no one else is willing no one else is
lazy enough to even think of the way to
lazily get around this thing he puts his
energy into being lazy he doubles down
on the laziness and it benefits him
that's insane and i was like that's
that's the difference obviously you have
to be [ __ ] smart to do that
but that's the difference between like
the caribbean mentality versus the
african mentality the african mentality
is like cool
give me the goal and give me the tools
to do it
big man
i'll do it i'll literally do it i don't
need sleep i'll just do it and once i'm
there then i'll sleep yeah where there
can be people i need to sleep yesterday
find me a way to pattern this quicker
tell me how to get from a to b fast bro
man because
people will move back to
people move back to nigeria to live
lavish people move back to jamaica to
live in a shed and be left alone
people will go back to jamaica with
seven pound in their hand i'm like
people have to do so i'm just not doing
this anymore sure i'm not doing this
anymore yeah
i can't handle this that's hilarious
so yeah i was thinking right you might
work hard
i ain't got time for it
there's not there's i've always said
that about you though especially like
toby as well actually he works [ __ ]
hard toby does aaron works hard i know
he does but just it's different
completely different
fields and stuff yeah yeah yeah you're
almost like a like a slave
everyone looks like there's no goal in
mind he just works
it doesn't make sense sometimes i have
to tell him stop
but you mean 12 hours
oh that's jokes i'm the laziest out of
everyone clearly
i i'm not willing to do anything the
thing is
yeah
i don't think you are you only think
that because
it's doing stuff you don't want to do
hmm i think that for everyone anyway
yeah yeah yeah um because if we're
actually talking about producing content
for the pod
you're one of the most hard working
people i know true
that's true
yeah i guess you're right so it all
depends on what you're focusing your
energy on yeah yeah it's true yeah i'm
i'm happy to work hard for like big boy
energy things
um
for things that i'm passionate about
yeah things i'm not passionate about i
can't even get out of bed
i can't do it bro bro when i had to do
overtime on friday um
i can imagine
that's just one day
i was like i'm i'm i'm gonna quit
i'm gonna quit if i had three extra
grand in my account on friday yeah i
would have walked out that day
i would have been like figure out i'm
not doing this i'm literally not doing
it you're just sat in nails what would
you have done a month later
i don't know that would have been a
month later problem that's november's
problem
oh well october james is happy chilling
october james was happy november james
is upset that's hilarious but bro i hate
being told what to do for science i know
i hate working
when it doesn't benefit
me
like in terms of like
for like if we're working hard for this
for example if someone turned around and
was like
cool like so for example
if for whatever reason
i had to work on this show
for this over the space of seven days
yeah for 65 hours
a week
for like two weeks
for whatever reason i can't even imagine
what would happen for me to have to do
that yeah but if that did i would know
at the end of those two weeks
something is different yeah yeah
something's pattern now even if it's
something small something is different
that's going to benefit us yeah forever
yeah
whereas at my work now for example
one of the trainers we were short
staffed
and one of the trainers had to step up
and put in so many more hours she was
working 63 hours a week for over a month
63 hours a week for over a month she was
working and obviously she got paid for
the extra hours that she did
but once that month was over and the
extra staff came back came in nothing
changed yeah
nothing changed and it's like you're
working
tirelessly for a month you're grinding
and what is there to show for it
literally nothing if i had to do that
for this for one week
we're making extra money probably
forever yeah something would have to
happen for us to work that hard yeah and
that long for just one week and she did
it for a month and when you get back to
nothing nothing's nothing different you
get a fat paycheck next month and that's
it
that's it
and it's fat but it's not even fat
like it's just
your normal wedge plus an extra whatever
[Music]
yeah
and it's not like there's no promotion
at the end of it there's nothing it's
just
cool man like thanks for hard work
here's a bit of change
like get back to where it normally was
there's nothing different bro
now
100 nah when you put it that way it's um
it's tough when you're in that right
race man working for someone else is
always going to be that way mom because
like you said as soon as you said that
you made me think of the restaurant oh
bro you're a prime example
you're a prime example no no no i know
there's too bad times that you've done
so much stuff that you told me about and
i'm like it just doesn't benefit me yeah
your christmas periods and stuff
i got an email today asking about send
us your christmas like requests for like
new year's and christmas eve blah blah i
was like [ __ ] i need to sort that asap
yeah oh fam yeah so yeah stuff like your
christmas periods and your busy periods
and stuff like that and you're just like
bro oh yeah i've just got to do this
thing and you get so you don't even get
paid extra for it
so you get less than my goal yeah
because she got paid extra for the extra
hours
[ __ ] you now some christmas period and
half terms
i'll swear half terms that's that's bare
half terms
half
are rampant bro really yeah that's
surprising to me yeah like uni students
or just like no parents and their kids
yeah really yeah
families come in
sundays are one of the worst days to
work period i said that to you this
sunday just yeah yeah because we just
get babies and families and it's just
long bro it's just long bro
oh it's just long bro it's just too many
more people yeah yeah you know during
the week
it's either
dates
like
um groups of friends like sixes fours or
couples but when you come in on a sunday
and it's families
and because it's a family thing your
family aren't always together so when
you're coming up for a family meal it's
an occasion yeah so you want everything
to be right yeah yeah yeah so it's just
longer for the staff and then it's just
long don't because this is maddening as
well right so say i own a restaurant
right yeah this is how i this happens to
my work a lot as well okay in terms of
like obviously pt people yeah
so at my work people don't know when i
train people at this part-time job that
i do
obviously we do
groups you have one-to-one you have
small grouping of large groups yeah so
regardless so let's just say right
and obviously the business wants to get
as many clients in the door as humanly
possible same with any business same
with any business same with restaurant
yeah
the more clients the better the more
customers the better the more money
everything
but for me personally
more clients just means more stress
i could be taking a class full of six
people
every wednesday for months and all of a
sudden
january rolls around
bear people want to get fit bare people
all of a sudden like these six people
i'm training 16 now i don't make an
extra penny the business makes p yeah
and i'm juggling now bear man about i
need to help everyone with everything
and like my job just got way harder
for no [ __ ] same with what you just
said like restaurants they want to get
as many people in there as possible so
these half terms these christmas periods
the people that don't even have to see
the customers they're sitting at yard
these shareholders
gas just
they're gas for christmas they're gas
they're getting paid this christmas
you're going to get the exact same money
and your job's way harder yeah
dead yeah man dead dead working for
someone else's death exponentially dead
bro
work on someone else is dead it's the
worst thing man but slowly but surely
we're getting out we're getting out and
then we're gonna this time next year we
won't be there so 100 percent this time
next it won't be in that situation
because like now when we do work work
yeah
we get paid
we're getting paid i pray for the day i
have to work 60 hours a week on this
thing because i'm getting oh oh yeah
[ __ ] out yeah i'm getting paid that
week jesus yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
there's no juggling up for for no extra
money that's not a thing yeah i'm not
moving for no extra money yeah yeah yeah
yeah so the work yeah sorry guys because
basically everyone works for someone
else yeah but yeah it's just dead
it's just so [ __ ] it is mom um anyway
back on track i've got a fan request
going i've liked this episode yeah this
is a long one some people have been
begging us for the long-form ones for
ages
because we haven't done like a long long
one in a while people are begging us for
one so this is i think this is quite a
long one
right so
front request
man said
what's good lads uh i've basically got a
little situation and i want to know if
you've been through it and what would
you do yeah so for context i'm 18
and obviously i'm horny 24 7.
so my standards are low lows
oh my god you've been there boy
we've all been there we've all been
there bro right okay i'll have to start
that again now [ __ ] out yeah so for
context i'm 18 and obviously i'm horny
24 7. so my standards are low low yeah
but on a night out i saw this sexy
looking thing and she even had a playboy
bunny tattoo that was on her thighs
so i had to move to her no other options
we start chatting this and that and i'm
getting the vibe that this [ __ ] is
crazy okay that's not where i thought it
was gonna be um
she was telling me she was married and
cheated on her man with a uber driver
that's pawn things
that is pawn things and that's that's
fake taxi things that's so far-fetched
fam's so far-fetched no one can say on a
night out he's 18. sorry it's called
he's 18. so i'm thinking she's around
the same age bracket nash this is big
woman
oh okay fair enough fair enough fair
enough this is fair enough yeah yeah
fair enough he used the term ting like
say
the yeah yeah the age base this is a
woman okay say a woman oh yeah because
she said married yeah she's been married
and she cheated on a man with an uber
driver
what kind of uber driver was this that's
a fake taxi thing galore it must have
been either her fetish or she's seen him
and felt you are the most banging uber
i've ever met yeah i have to smash you
yeah i have to smash you yeah yeah
[ __ ] that was gosh that day
the uber driver was good come back today
we'll come back yeah yeah anyway
long story short i managed to go back to
hers and we're hooking up and everything
but i left my condom in the car and
acted like i didn't bring one been there
now obviously this chick is nuts so she
she was like even better
because she asked how good my pull-out
game is
or maybe quiver that made me swallow
spit
now i'm 18. so obviously i don't even
have a pull-up
yeah but i told her yeah i've done it
i'm a pro
you say anything in heat at the moment
you say anything uh long story short we
um
we bang i put up a solid performance
finish the job and left
two weeks later this [ __ ] texted me i
think i'm pregnant
and wants to get a smush motion
but i was confident that i pulled out at
the perfect time yeah
um
so i didn't buy it
and did what any good gentleman would do
and blocked her immediately
yeah any good gentleman you know
that is hilarious
that sweetened meat yeah what any good
gentleman would do and blocked her
immediately immediately
oh my chest up
jesus christ a couple days later she
messages my number that i forgot that i
gave her and says oh you don't have to
worry i went to the doctors and
apparently the test was incorrect
i'm not pregnant so we're good
basically i was like blessed no drama
now this chick texting me saying she
wants the whole man's tool again
the question is do i go back again or
lock it off keep in mind
uh the chick is bath
i also want to know if you men have had
any similar situations and what would
you have done in my position
that's a mad thing i think
knowing the kind of person i am
especially knowing the kind of person i
was when i was 18. what 3000 quite a few
relationships when i was a lot younger
but
needless to say a horny 18 year old if
he's secured prime milf [ __ ]
yeah considering the fact she's banged
the [ __ ] uber driver you already know
what she's about
you already know she's frivolous in this
lifestyle oh yeah so
even though the scare was there
you already know i'm going back you
already know i'm going back bro you just
have to either a bring a dom yeah bring
a johnny 100 or actively work on that
pull-out game because i'm going back
there's no question there's no question
in it if i'm 18 i'm going back i'm going
back 100 100 bro
100 there's no there's no
there's no reasoning about it you just
have to
you just have to
because that's a once not necessarily
once in a lifetime experience because
you're potentially going back or you've
already gone back regardless but he's
gone back it's uh yeah you've got when
he said that he's been back he's been
back already um it's just one of them
was you can't let that opportunity pass
you up because she's going to get bored
of you sooner or later she's going to
move on she [ __ ] an uber drive for
[ __ ] sake she's not going to she was
married yeah she's not going to while
she was married she's not going to be
she's going to be done with you very
soon you're going to be done with you in
a month so grab that grab that
opportunity bro
she's gonna be done with you in a month
oh my days bruv but bro if i was that
uber driver imagine that com how that
conversation is even patterning she's
obviously in the back seat i'm driving
now whipping looking in the rearview i
can see she's looking at me and i know
she's paying this is literally
one of
the fantasies for every man like
this is why he became a newbie this is
literally why he signed those documents
i'm trying to secure some messages what
if this happens what he's told him
it's a possibility bro bro
your roommates were just giggling about
it like imagine imagine imagine you're
picking up what you're doing in the late
nights and all these things that i heard
that farook down the road was was
patting in the something
[ __ ]
[ __ ] trust me he said he banged the
thing in the alleyway now first time
[ __ ] bro you can never bang a thing in
that alloy like trust me i think you can
might have been working it for three
years never had any sniff of nine
nothing and then one day a ting of
playboy bunnies on her thighs
they're talking smoke bro and you see it
live man's just in the car drive away
again where are your head love she just
says oh salford
you're driving now you're at media city
for example so it's about it's it's a
good 10 minute journey so you've got you
can make conversation you can start
saying you're driving now you're on the
m you're on the motorway and you can see
in the rear view she's looking she's
looking at you he's like her eyes are
piercing blue so you can see in the dark
it's one of them once you can see your
eyes it's piercing blue and the white is
white so all you can see is clean it's
clean yeah yeah yeah clean yeah yeah
it's one of the ones you kind of you
kind of shimmy the thing yeah so you can
see is she looking up here can i see the
back well yeah you can see she's she's
she's wearing this one is the sexiest
outfit there's sex she's got [ __ ]
fishnets on
she's come back from a night out she's
got the fish net she's got the heels
she's got a little skirt she's got
liquor in a system
you can see the you can see the tat yeah
you can see the titan upper thigh you're
thinking
the tts are healthy the lips are juicy
and the eyes are piercing they hear the
hair's flowing and you're thinking oh my
i've just picked up a 10 out of 10. yeah
yeah wherever you want to go babes let's
take the long route yeah yeah because
i'm trying to converse with you i'm
trying to see what you're wrong
i'm trying to see what you're running
bro
so you start talking start talking you
start get she starts getting like she
starts bringing up conversations oh
where you from blah blah blah all this
chit chat you're just you're there smite
you're smiling you're trying to hold the
smirk because it's like sweating i will
fix my life this can't be real yeah this
can't be real you're thinking oh my days
bro
talking talking talking now and she's
looking at you looking at her and
thinking
i'm trying to have some fun today i'm
trying to have some fun if i go back to
my husband what are you saying
you look look at the thing like excuse
me
you adjust the mirror excuse me
you heard what i said i'm trying to have
some fun before i go back to my husband
what are you saying
she says exactly what she said word for
word
you park up you look back
it's not it's not a review anymore you
look back
yeah yeah you look back you look down
and you look up you see she's spread out
now now she couldn't she could she's
just spreading legs legs spread out just
looking at you licking
no
no
no
ah james said i should stop the story so
i'm not exploring 100
never
100
never in a million years oh could that
ever happen
that's too intense that's something
that's fake taxi it could never happen
that's too
intense for me for had my whole be up my
chest i'll be excited and nervous at the
same time i'll be terrified bro i'll be
terrible above fear all over again
terrified oh my god because you have to
perform you have to perform that's too
much going on yeah there's too much
stimulus
because i will not last in that
situation i'm not like she can never
continue to come back to the backseat we
need to find like a neutral
area we need to bring this back to
baseline and then work up again because
this is too
you're not having any fun cause i'm
gonna have a whale of a time this is all
for me because this is all too much
you did this to yourself this is all too
much ah
that's too much stimulus can't deal with
that kind of pressure bro speaking of
pressure some guy messaged me like
yesterday yeah yesterday he knows about
this thing one young buck
he sent me a screenshot of some
conversation like literally like a
cougar trying to bang some young guy
um
i think he sent it to either saying to
me you'll send it to us as well but tell
me what you're going to say because i
feel like i've got something similar
okay so
he sent me a message conversation on
facebook yes i've got it then cougars
are signing out yes i've got the exact
same thing i've got exact same one
message my man said you're so handsome
young man
man
said
la mama
must say thank you la mama
she said i'm no little mama i'm 38 years
old i'm a grown ass woman and i come
after what i want
and i want you
i'll make my heart beat i see how you be
talking on facebook you probably do have
a big tool
but can you use it properly
bro
you won't be all in me just wrecking
[ __ ] you got to know how to use that
thing right
you won't want for anything either i
promise you that
that i can't receive that kind of
message
listen fam
the bread said into me said i can't lie
if that was me it would
it would feel like i'm going to war when
i packed my bags to go to a house i'm
scared
i replied to him said fab that's too
much pressure
going to war that is hilarious
that's too
much
pressure
the my man's response was the funniest
thing in this text oh then once a day
what does it say i've already said that
once a day multivitamins for women got
your ass aggressive as hell on this
tuesday afternoon
when i read that i was like [ __ ] hell
that's hilarious that is funny
i screenshotted that and i was purposely
going to say it as well but i completely
forgot so i'm happy no one could message
me that
brother i will be replying shaken i
think this is all a hoax it can't be
real it can't be real who's catfishing
you'll want for nothing i'll tell you
that
what
you're trying to pay man's bills
my sack will be empty and my bank will
be healthy
nah
nah that's the dream that is the dream
as a young 18 year old man the dream is
the dream of dreams
nothing good happened to me when i was
18. not a single thing
not a single good thing happening while
i was 18.
it's a piss tape
uh we live at a different time now bro
we really do [ __ ] it up we really
[ __ ] do
uh
cool yeah we definitely answered your
question but yeah um we'll see you guys
on thursday
[Music]
you